monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre cheikh collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
de l'environnement
rappelez vous noterez octobre 2015
département des alpes maritimes a été
frappé par de dramatiques intempéries
faisant 20 morts plus de 30 mille
sinistrés plusieurs centaines de
millions de dégâts
suite à ce drame le conseil
départemental les intercommunalités et
les communes des alpes-maritimes ont
créé le syndicat mixte inondation
aménagement et gestion de l'eau marc
alpin 10 mirage chargé de gérer le
facteur inondations et déterminer
l'ensemble des travaux indispensables en
collaboration avec les services de
l'état et des agences publiques
les aménagements urgent était donc
parfaitement identifiés pour assurer la
protection maximum des personnes et des
biens entre 22 et 25 novembre 2009
les pluies diluviennes inondée à nouveau
le var et les alpes maritimes
plus de vingt mille foyers sinistrés
d'innombrables effondrement éboulements
nécessitant des centaines de relogement
pour beaucoup les mêmes victimes qu'en
2015 une personne n'aurait trouvé à ce
jour et cinq morts au cours de ce drame
l'ensemble des forces de sécurité
services municipaux avec leur mère ont
été remarquables par leur engagement
terrain depuis 2015 la dréal freine
retardent et va jusqu'à bloquer la
réalisation des travaux urgents et
indispensables identifié au prétexte de
la protection des espèces dites
protégées batraciens on plante en tout
genre et lorsqu'une étude se termine
elle en ordonne une nouvelle si les
travaux parfaitement identifiées par le
sz nuages avaient été réalisés des vies
des dégâts humains et matériels aurait
sans doute pu être évité
madame la ministre ne pensez vous pas
aujourd'hui qu'il est indispensable de
créer une procédure d'urgence pour
anticiper et faire face à ce genre de
situation qui se multiplient par
ailleurs allez vous donner des
instructions à la dréal pour faciliter
les dossiers en cours et faire passer
les vies humaines
avant les espèces protégées ce qui n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]